my mum
has always thought that she's not
mathematical actually always being told
by her school by various different
people that she's not mathematical but
there are always a few clues that i saw
throughout my life i thought hang on i
actually think you might be good at
maths so first of all she's pretty good
at textiles my mum once crocheted me
this wonderful festive poncho the
boundary of which is a digon and it
doesn't lie flat so you're crocheting in
hyperbolic space
um and also on all of her letters any
like birthday cards everything i get she
always draws this little symbol
okay everything for my seal
so this little symbol you'll recognize
this as the three one knot it's got
three crossings it is a closed knot and
it is the smallest non-trivial prime
knot
to seal in mum's mathematical abilities
and embrace her into the world of maths
i thought i would give her a
mathematical embrace so welcome to
alien's guide on how to give a
mathematically interesting hug
featuring lorna
so let's investigate first of all a
normal
normal hugs so there's the first one
here if you're just holding hands this
is
not a hug
this would be like the unknot it's just
a loop not a hug at all
if you were to look at a normal hug so
usually one person goes over one person
goes under i'm the shorty of the family
so i always go under this would be your
normal hug which is two linked loops and
i don't think it's great because
without unlinking you can just you can
escape like that so it's two it's two
unhugs joined together um every so often
you get a kind of
the awkward hug where you don't know if
someone's gonna go over or under and you
end up doing one person over one person
under which looks like this
which
is better because you are linked and but
we can do we can take that one step
further we can do even better than that
here is your symbol in a hug the trefoil
knot three one as a hug
so step number one uh the person behind
you're going to have to do the over
under so i'm going to go left arm under
right arm over
then you're going to reverse that
situation so cross over here and you
just need to hold my hands
cool and this although it doesn't look
like it is a trefoil hug we can do a
continuous deformation
so we do it like this
there is the trefoil knot that's the
trefoil hug i'm sure you can like draw
on there
to show that it is definitely a trifle
hug we've got three crossings and we're
completely linked we're all tied
together
i'm there is something i do want to show
you about the chirality of that hug
though
so the way that mum draws this it just
kind of loops all together but you can
draw this as an alternating knot all
knots which have less than eight
crossings are alternating so if i start
here
so here is as an alternating knot
where it goes under over under over
under so it continues with the under
over but
there is another
so you can do this again but instead of
starting going over you can start going
under
so if i draw the exact same knot but
with an under to start with
this is like doing something left handed
for me
[Music]
hopefully i haven't drawn the same knot
nope it's all good okay so these two
knots they both have three crossings
they're both a trifoil not but they are
different they have chirality which is
like a handedness so they've got a
left-handed knot and a right-handed knot
chirality such an interesting symmetry
and you can see that in the hug so back
to
[Laughter]
back to the hugs so if we did the one
that we did before i
what we do one over one under
cross it join
you can only deform this in one way so
you can only do it like this
where it goes over the left hand side
you want to go back in
if you try and go the other way
it it doesn't work it doesn't work
because of the chirality it only has one
direction so if you wanted to do the
other sided knot rather than going left
hand under right hand over i would have
to go this way round
and this one's over so it's going to go
under join and then now we should be
able to go the other way
so
chirality
which hug did you like best mum
um
just the plain old good hug
yeah she's over complicating things
it's always okay to hug your mum any way
you like
i have tried this is gonna make me sound
like such a sad person
i've tried to do these hug knots on my
own
it doesn't work
how what do you even do well so this
this trefoil knot the three button knot
is sometimes called the overhand knot